I'm sure that
this story is not going to come as a surprise
to a lot of people in our audience because
you already probably knew the likely truth,
but there are some explosive new leaked emails
that seem to confirm that yes, Donald Trump
personally ordered
that aid to Ukraine be frozen until such time
that smear investigations into Joe and Hunter
Biden were publicly announced by the Ukrainians
and it feels like this is almost a story from
years ago.
It is from last year.
Technically, uh, because it is so obvious
what we are now learning.
But indeed the leaked emails are communications
between the Pentagon and the white house is
OMB office of management and budget.
And in the emails, a staffer for the OMB,
Mike Duffy emailed the Pentagon and said,
quote, clear direction from POTUS to hold
meaning clear direction from the president
of the United States to hold the aid to Ukraine.
This is one sentence which makes it very clear
that these are the president's orders.
The orders are hold the aid to Ukraine, period.
Now, there are many more emails.
The other emails don't explicitly repeat that
these are Trump's orders.
But that's the context.
That's the framing.
That's the obvious reality that we have a
suspected.
For a very long time, this was Trump's call,
it was Trump's call.
All along, people were acting at the direction
of Donald Trump.
Now there's other emails that are interesting
that have leaked and we're still going through
them.
Uh, and in an a, another email involving a
secretary of defense, Mark Espers, chief of
staff, McCusker.
Miss McCusker said in an email when the Pentagon
was ordered not to release, the aide.
McCusker said, you can't be serious.
I am speechless.
So the lie that Donald Trump wasn't doing
this wasn't involved, that it wasn't deliberate,
those were all just that they were lies.
Let's address another issue that's been sort
of wrapped up in this that's important to
get to.
At this point.
There is a wing of the left that is starting
to implicitly or explicitly excuse Donald
Trump's behavior in this Ukraine fiasco by
saying we shouldn't even be arming Ukraine,
right?
So there's this, this wing of the left that's
saying we are funding Ukraine's military as
a proxy war against Russia and I don't like
that.
Okay, this is, this is a lot of people, a
M, uh, on the left from the slice of the left,
they were saying this, some of the people
saying this are part of the revolutionary
left as we've decided to non pejoratively
refer to it.
Others are merely contrarians.
Okay.
Let me see if I can be sort of clear here
in how I say this.
You can be against the foreign policy decision
to give you crane money for weapons.
You can be against what Ukraine is doing with
the weapons.
I don't care.
That's fine.
That's legitimate political discussion.
It does not change the corruption and bribery
of the Trump administration using the military
aid as a way to strong arm Ukraine into publicly
announcing smear investigations into Joe and
Hunter Biden for the benefit of Donald Trump's
2020 reelection.
I'm fine discussing whether we should be arming
Ukraine or Saudi Arabia or Israel or any country.
Those are perfectly reasonable political discussions,
but much like I'm fine discussing whether
Hunter Biden's board position on the Ukrainian
gas company is appropriate.
Those are not actually the issues here.
And it is serving as a really great way to
enable Donald Trump's behavior to implicitly
defend Donald Trump's behavior to help Donald
Trump avoid consequences to split the left
about impeachment.
We shouldn't participate in that period.
So, uh, I, I respect the position.
I respected the debate about who should the
United States provide military aid to, who
should we be arming?
What about, uh, supposedly proxy Wars that
the United States has waged for decades?
I mean, look at Latin America.
There's so many different examples.
These are legitimate discussions.
I have no interest in shutting down those
discussions.
But where the slice of the left goes too far
is when they played directly into, uh, the
goals of the Trumpists, which are to muddy
the waters and to make the issue of Trump's
corruption and bribery about something else.
To make it an adjudication of Ukraine versus
Russia to make it about Joe Biden to make
it about Hunter Biden.
It's going to get Trump re-elected if it takes
hold.
And we don't want to do that now to go back
to the league deal, right?
I don't think we do.
Maybe there are some on the revolutionary
left who do want that, who are saying if it's
not going to be whoever they want, they almost
would rather it be Trump part of this, break
it all down to build it back up mentality.
I don't subscribe to that.
I know that there are some people who do.
Let's get back to the emails.
The white house knew these emails were damaging
to their narrative and the white house blocked
these documents from being turned over to
the house for their impeachment inquiry.
Once again, it's not hugely surprising and
this of course throws a wrench into Mitch
McConnell's plans.
Mitch McConnell was hoping to keep these documents
out of the eventual Senate impeachment trial.
Now that they've leaked, now that we know
that they exist, I don't know how you justify
keeping them out of the trial.
We'll see if McConnell is able to come up
with something.
Once again, if we want this guy held accountable,
we're going to have to vote them out in 10
months.
It is not looking like there is going to be
any other path to holding him accountable.
Even being impeached.
We can't count on the Senate.
We're going to have to vote them out in November
of 2020, 20.
And uh, the fundraising around November of
2020 is
what I want
to
talk
about next.